it's a five alarm fire according to
border patrol agents with sources
telling Fox News Monday set a new record
for daily migrant Crossings all as the
total Encounters in December usually a
quieter time at the border expected to
set another new monthly record the New
York Post says the record numbers Pro
President Biden has waved the white flag
and his administration is ignoring the
laws and just letting everybody in bill
mugan is live at the Border in lukeville
Arizona for us you've been seeing these
large groups of mostly adult men cross
all day Bill what exactly are you seeing
there well Sandra you can see over my
shoulder we have another group of adult
men who have crossed illegally here and
these border numbers are just spiraling
out of control in the month of December
we are currently averaging 10,000
migrant encounters every single day this
is the situation here in lukeville a lot
of these adults coming in from all
around the planet uh actually had a
couple of guys from Afghanistan out here
a little bit earlier they are considered
special interest aliens they will be
subject to additional vetting but we'll
show you how all these guys got here
take a look at this footage we shot just
a couple of hours ago they were part of
a group of 500 that crossed illegally
early this morning through an open
breach in the border wall cut by
Smugglers uh they then marched up here
to this outdoor border patrol processing
area where we're standing right now some
of them had their iPhones out they were
taking selfies sending images back home
to let folks know they had arrived here
successfully in the United States as
this Tucson Arizona sector just remains
overwhelmed in the epicenter of this
border crisis right now more than 2,800
illegal Crossings yesterday alone we
actually had a chance to catch up with
some Indian guys who had crossed
illegally had a little chat with them
take a listen where are you guys from
India India India everybody here from
India India where do you guys want to go
in the United States what city
California California California
everybody here California new Jersey
Seattle New York New York okay and why
did you guys come here to the US sorry
English English no English do do you
want to work you want a job yes yes no
what no you don't want to
work why' you life danger life in
danger and then take a look at this we
talk about how backlog the Asylum system
is this is a notice for a Colombian
woman who crossed illegally and was
released into the US for her to check in
with ice in New York City and look at
the date
2031 8 years from now I talked to her
immigration attorney he says he was left
absolutely stunned and he's been doing
this job for almost 30 years take a
listen they gave her a return notice to
come back in
2031 uh so that's quite possibly the
most unusual things thing I've ever seen
in my near three decades of practice
practicing immigration law it made me
realize that uh the Biden Administration
is basically providing back door amnesty
for anyone that wants to show up at the
border and John and Sandra one more
thing to note last week Arizona's
Democrat Governor ktie Hobs announced
she was sending the national guard down
here to the Arizona border I can tell
you we've been here in lukeville all
week long we have not seen a single
National Guard Soldier out here yet
we'll send it back to you hey Bill it's
Sean let me come back to the
conversation that you have with the
illegal immigrants who came from India
where you were asking them are you here
to work and they're like yeah yeah yeah
and then the one fellow pipes up and
says oh no no life danger I mean we all
know that in order to qualify for a
claim for asylum in this country you
have to demonstrate what's called
credible fear did that sound like it was
coached to
you it did and that happens a lot these
migrants are told by the cartels what to
say when they get here on us soil so
they can be be released into the United
States incredible fear is one of those
thresholds they have to meet they do
these initial credible fear interviews
out here in the field and uh look if
they come here and say no I want a job I
want to work that does not qualify for
Asylum so some of these migrants know uh
they're told what to say when they get
here and if they say uh my life is in
danger or I I'm in fear of my home
country they feel that's a box they can
check in order to get Asylum and
hopefully be released and you just saw
that court date uh not a court date an
ice hearing for uh 8 years from now in
2031 it's ridiculous how backlogged the
system is I mean when you put this in
perspective bill as we're heading in to
the final days of the year here as we
remind our viewers you wouldn't be
seeing this happen unless we had drone
images like this that our Fox flight
team is providing for our viewers and
really for the country and the world to
see this happening but when you put this
in perspective and you see what cities
like Chicago are dealing with they're
blaming Texas for busting these migrants
up there they're saying they're at
capacity they've received to date 2
6,000 migrants they say you've got
12,000 a day record numbers pouring over
a day at the border yet you have some of
these blue cities and blue States saying
it's Texas's
fault yeah well look a lot of these blue
cities have been getting reality checks
right I mean a couple years ago you had
New York city mayor Eric Adams tweeting
that New York City will remain a
sanctuary city under his administration
and they'd be proud to do so now he's
saying quote the city is going to be
destroyed this is coming to your
neighborhood uh ktie Hobbs has been
critical about what other Republican
Governors have done at the border
particularly Governor Abbot now she's
sending the national guard down here uh
to the Border or allegedly we still have
not seen them yet um so yeah I mean
there was no criticism when the blue
city of El Paso was busing migrants to
New York City they busted tens of
thousands there was no criticism when
Katie Hobbs a Democrat Governor of
Arizona kept Governor Doug Ducey a
Republicans busing program to also bust
migrants out of Arizona so the criticism
only seems to be at Governor Abbott and
Governor DeSantis when they move
migrants around the country despite the
fact that Democrats have been doing it
and the federal government has been
doing it as well with
NOS when you take a look at that group
of people you know they can't all stay
in Texas they got to go somewhere Bill
you've been doing terrific reporting
down there at the border and I dare say
that yours are the only images of this
that we're seeing pretty much anywhere
on television keep up the good
work thank you Bill I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis